Yeah, perfect.
Let's just
I've already been doing some refactors
today. Getting pretty old.
You know, it's it's not super fun just
having to go through large amounts of
like AI assisted and AI gen code.
This is kind of just the state of things
at the moment, though.
And it's far better that I go through it
than I don't.
Somebody has to.
Okay. So,
little bit of selfplay plumbing.
Okay. So, we have run sweep
called from
here.
Okay. So, it's just like a bare
comparison. It's fine.
Little janky. Not bad, though.
path.
Wait. Path.
Big train block.
Run train.
Uh structurally though this is
run eval run train run. This is actually
structurally not very bad.
At least this is very easy to see where
everything is, right?
Okay.
Very procedural. That's what we like.
I mean, that's just generally
good, you Oh,
Where's the workout equipment? At the
farm. I'm in California for the uh the
summer. I do have a little uh a little
gym set up here, but I'm mostly just
running.
I keep my bench up.
But other than that, I'm mostly running.
I've lost a lot of weight. I am very,
very lean right now.
I know a lot of people like Pelatons. I
[ __ ] hate those things. I don't want
anybody yapping at me while I exercise.
I want to be like left the [ __ ] alone to
listen to a book or whatever I'm doing
RL and the greater landscape.
I mean, you're in the right place for
it. Like the stuff we're doing here is
very different from what is going on
elsewhere.
Um, it's moving quite quickly.
We don't have like crazy sexy
algorithmic advances, though we do have
a few like consistent good things with a
huge amount of Perf optimization and new
tasks and lots of experiments.
Uh stuff that was like nearly impossible
a couple years ago is working almost out
of the box today. I think we're pretty
much we're definitely less than a year
out from being able to just RL whatever
we want.
Like any reasonably defined problems.
[ __ ]
Honestly, language models are not a
reasonable RL problem.
It's a really stupid RL problem where
you kind of just have to light money on
fire to make it work.
I don't know if we actually want this.
Let me think.
I don't dislike language models at all.
Like
I dislike
um
these companies like
just trying to consume the entire scope
of AI under language models when they're
clearly the wrong model for a number of
problems and diverting all attention and
90% of the best people away from other
problems that they were working on.
The thing is I don't even hate hype.
Like,
you know, when Dota 2 was happening,
that was super hype and all the
academics were being like crusty old
bastards about it when it was genuinely
awesome.
Like, it's fine to be super excited and
enthusiastic about work. The problem in
my mind is not that. It's when it
becomes like a mass marketing thing and
you and then people just start very very
clearly just [ __ ] lying about
everything to the detriment of other
areas of science,
you know.
All right, let's figure this.
Hello, Jess.
Uh, some cleanups.
Just a few cleanups.
I'm basically on that chunk of the code
in a second.
Uh FYI
It's very funny how like you can point
all the LLMs you want at your code, but
then if I just go through it myself, I
always find more cuts
It's like they're not the same thing.
Literally telling me that two pointers
to the same address are somehow
different,
man.
Continuous
control works end.
I'd certainly hope we have chest and
puffer
It loves to like save lines by gulfing
oneline if statements. It just it
doesn't understand the point of
anything. It's weird.
This is kind of ridiculous how bad this
is,
you know.
Can you mix continuous?
Um, I forget whether or not I added
that.
I think I didn't because it would be
like another 200 lines.
If it ends up mattering, I will add it.
But I didn't for now, I don't think.
for what though?
We still have not even bothered doing
the study like whether continuous
matters at all.
A lot of the continuous stuff gets
discretized normally.
Yeah, but that doesn't give you realism.
Like that's not a thing.
minute of ads. So, Kvert, was it not
doing that before like a few days ago?
I guess you can't hear me. I'll ask in a
minute.
Let me show you this.
Don't think there's anything sensitive
here, right?
Okay, let me show you guys this.
So,
Does this cut the ads out if I do this
or does this just make it like not let
me manage them?
this apparently doesn't fix it.
So, I can do this. Look, I can do this
here,
but it will have
It'll put pre-roll ads.
So, this will be 30 seconds of ads per
hour.
I don't know whether this hurts
discoverability and stuff.
That's very annoying though that the
experience gets worse because I got
affiliate and now you all are getting
more ads. That's not good. Twitch.
I can do this. I guess
we'll see if this does anything helpful.
That's then that's minimum ads. That's
30 seconds an hour.
I didn't actually see the airplane
design. Wait, what? Did I miss
something?
There's no way you're modeling full a
like full aerodynamics at 700 kPS,
right? or 7 mil SPS, right?
That's very cool though.
I mean in like edge type applications
that is the type of stuff we want to do.
Estimate. Yeah. So convert in order to
actually get that to work.
You're not that that far off, but you
need to have you probably need two or
maybe three levels of simulator there.
You need like a fast sim, you need a
medium verifier sim, and then you need
like the really slow actual full thing.
So, I suspect if it's 7 mil, you just
wrote the really fast one.
That's actually really [ __ ] cool.
Then
what are you cooking? I'm just trying to
clean up the five puffer five release.
I see that would leak. I did. That's the
wrong one. Okay.
That's fine.
Why do we of
No, wait. This is This is fine, right?
Yeah. Yeah, this is fine.
This one can go
fix this [ __ ]
and we will be able to continue. We're
actually a good way through this.
Can't just have one lines for important
stuff like this.
There's also there's one major thing
with the CUDA usage here which is this
is not robust to CUDA falling off of
Docker.
Annoying.
I think that's fine. It's defensive, but
that's a catastrophic fail check. It'd
be very difficult to figure out
Uh, unstable hypers mostly if nothing's
wrong with the env.
Hello Tim. Um, mostly cleaning up puffer
5C.
Almost done.
Oh, did I miss this? No, I didn't. Wait,
what?
like to the point that we're set on. I
it would basically be that we can't find
a problem that we throw at it where it
fails in any way where there's like
reasonably
a path for it to succeed
which is vague but basically we just
keep throwing it at problems and then
our default algorithm is just good. We
solve everything that can be solved with
predictable scaling.
Like
from there it's it's not so much solved
as it's like a mature established thing
where uh progress becomes incremental
and we can kind of just use it to solve
whatever we want.
There's some cleanup. There's some
experiment stuff. Uh well I mean there's
like some experimental stuff to make
sure we haven't broken anything. There's
env integrations. There's a little bit
of release work and I also have
professional things to be doing in that
time.
Critical states. Yeah. So what happened
with that is we had a a major contract
that needed some selfplay progress which
that added so much code to puffer that
um it basically made sense to do the
major refactor cleanup and port to uh C
and CUDA everything first. So like
functionally we are just switching the
deliverables of puffer five with puffer
six. So puffer six is going to have more
algo stuff. Puffer five is PF major
cleanup uh everything into nice
all cudy etc etc.
We did make some progress on the algo
stuff, but then I had to do
No. So, broadly, Jess, um, we are not
developing
broadly useful RL techniques for
companies that don't go back into
Puffer.
It would be very hard to get us to sign
a contract like that. closed sources,
general purpose RL improvements.
And like when we do a contract
um in an area where we have tools, but
the tools aren't fully matured and
tested, it basically just involves more
manual work than it would involve if we
did have those tools fully matured and
tested.
So, there's some fiddling for sure.
What are we doing? We're doing cleanups
for the uh Puffer 5 release. I'm trying
to get this release down to roughly
10,000 lines.
Um,
let's just say Arch that by the time it
releases there probably will be some
substantial changes.
Self play is just really annoyingly
complicated
and we're trying to get it to be simple.
Yeah, this is definitely a mess. How
much code we have in here? That's not
that much.
do we need to do this through GPU? I
wonder.
I actually there was a conversation on X
where I hope I was hoping I would get a
reply from um
Susan but apparently not
unfortunate.
hang on me think
to render this from GPU.
Yes, because if the end of his GPU it
has to Okay.
Yeah. No, chess. The goal is not to make
the best chess agent, though that would
be nice. It's more so like taking a hard
problem and then doing it with very
simple RL. Actually, just the um I'm
still waiting on the conditional action
treat. Let me ask Finn.
I think Finn's probably Yeah, Finn's got
to be asleep, so he'll reply tomorrow.
The fin turn.
Pancake.
What?
function
11 p.m. on a Friday. Doubt he's asleep.
I'm [ __ ] asleep most of the time. at
11:00 p.m. on a Friday.
[snorts]
There actually is a pancake. That's
funny.
When were you at uni?
graduated 2019.
I think technically speaking, I took
three and 1/3 years, but then I just
because it wasn't a a full integer, I
just went to the normal graduation.
Oh, did I go to sleep at 11 p.m. when I
was in university? Hell no. I was out
blackout drunk at a party somewhere.
2,000 ELO
dogfish is deeper is weaker at depth
zero.
Uh yeah, that would be pretty cool.
So, Jess, the continuous action tree
that should prevent you from having to
do two actions per move, right?
I'm not sure how you implemented it, but
like it should be back to one
like one turn move.
It seemed to work well.
Well, when you say it seemed to work
well, like did you just immediately get
a better policy or is it like, oh, okay,
it runs or what?
Was it faster? like was like, you know,
what what does that
Oh, wait. I'm sorry. I missed your
message. I was just blleh.
Learned about as well when adjusting for
time steps.
I want to sweep more. See if I can find
better configs.
More steps per second. Yeah, exactly.
You should get double
checkers about one to one. I mean,
that's good then, Jess, isn't it?
Like, that's about what you would
expect.
So, 2x versus the full thing and
removing the weird jankiness of the
credit assignment. That seems like a
good enough win, doesn't it?
the way that you were doing it before.
It should be almost identical.
You can thank Chris Bamford for that on
X. original author did a lot of great RL
work before he got bought out by LLMs.
I was paused and thought he was really
focused. [laughter]
Got him.
Uh,
Make sure this doesn't do anything
stupid.
Um, the reason I'm doing this, by the
way, I do not care at all about the uh
breakout GPU code.
I hop on voice. Yeah, when I do code
reviews sometimes.
I used to do that more. I don't know
why. I just kind of got sucked into the
ordev. There's just so much to fix on
the core.
I mean, at least we found some good cuts
here, right? Like, yeah, we're at 3470
lines,
which is good timing because we're at
what, like 85% through this.
Finished masters did not work.
Congratulations.
Congrats.
RL's hard
good results proper using ideas from
Puffer. Hey, that's awesome to hear.
Yeah, it's it's really cool to see more
people getting into the space um just by
virtue of like making stuff faster and
simpler.
I don't know if you've seen this result
yet.
Little bit of seed sensitivity on it.
Do this.
Yeah, there you go. Check this out.
Ready? We train breakout. Boom. Trained.
Dutch imbalance market.
Huh,
that's cool.
trade with many strategies with respect
to usage and returns.
Hang on a second. Let me I I got to do
one thing real quick. I'll be back in
one minute.
All right,
go back
into everything.
Wait, single policy trade multi
strategies
X and C match uh RLDEV reinforcement
learning
trained everything on my personal
laptop. Trillions of steps throughout
testing. Trillions of steps on a 3070 is
a lot.
millions of seconds.
10 days continuous. What?
Millions of
No, we do trillions of steps of
experiments, but we do it on like at
least eight GPUs.
Typically
we actually can get that amount of data
but on one like not top end GPU that's a
Oh, millions of steps for 10 days
straight.
Oh, that's reasonable then, actually.
depending on the end of puffer can
output at well our latest version can
get up to 50 million steps per second
but typically people are in like the
high singledigit millions for like a
decently optimized thing with a
mediumsiz policy
by our standards
interested in an M is just working on
IRL data. I have one gigabyte of market
data. Oh, okay. I see what you mean.
Well,
it really depends what how you're
formulating the problem, right? Because
there still has to be an interaction of
some sort. We have actually done stuff
in finance sort of like that before. So,
if you have a different way of
formulating stuff like yeah, that'd be
very interesting.
In fact, depending on the quality of
your work, I might even know some uh
professional contracts who'd be
interested.
Trillions of steps in aggregate during
my work. Yeah, that actually does make
sense. That is good. That is good.
Typically individual projects require
like a cross testing. Yeah, that's in
the ballpark for a complex enth.
Our current project is actually probably
in like the 10 trillion plus territory
with the number of experiments we've
done, but that's for like larger
projects where you're kind of rushing
and have to just run a lot of stuff at
the same
Don't get on static.
I have also actual thesis. Oh yeah. If
you want to make a demo, um what I would
suggest for web like look at any of our
stuff that we do in Ray. If you just get
the viz in, uh into ray, you can just
build the whole thing to web assembly.
Can't share it yet. Let me know when it
is.
It's generally it's a good idea to get
your work out there. I mean, unless you
want to like go directly build a company
off of it or something like that.
Depends what you're trying to do.
No, I don't really follow um LM research
most of the time.
Front end thesis not going for PhD one
years
a doing kind of stuff with LMS. Yeah. So
that's the annoying thing, right, about
um
like a specific area of a field blowing
up is then all of a sudden all the money
gets just drained over to that
Oh yeah, there was a bunch of crap in
here. That just made its way in. Nice.
Okay.
deep learning solution or product doing
that all day would be ideal.
I mean we do have work in that space man
but Puffer is a small lab and we
basically we don't take funding so we
really only grow at the rate that we
grow client work.
So, we don't just like have interviews
or whatever for full-time positions.
I will keep that in mind though for um
for professional stuff, particularly in
finance. There are quite a number of
people that have um
uh there are quite a number of finance
people that want like RL SIMs and
whatnot.
A lot of them tend to be less technical
though, so you really have to bring them
back down to to earth on like
thing that makes sense versus on.
Ah yeah, Kvert knows actually ask on
that stuff. Perfect.
How much more do we have? We have 600
lines left to edit.
See reduction.
Uh so modeling that like stuff like that
is part of what you would negotiate.
I mean with Puffer we like we do a
number of different things when we think
we can just solve somebody's problem.
Sometimes we'll say like yeah we can
just solve this for you for this price.
But sometimes like people want a sim
that they can do other stuff with and
then it's basically like okay the sim
will support this the sim will support
that you know the sim will model this it
won't model that right
we'll have a baseline RL integration
with puffer lib that will achieve 5
million step per second training with a
policy of such and such size provided
you don't put any other stuff in our
loop that's slow
you
We've definitely learned our lesson on
underscoping. Like for our type of work,
it's very important that we scope what
we're going to deliver.
Cuz actually, it's very funny. We don't
ever have a problem on not being able to
deliver something for a client. We've
literally never had that problem. The
only problems we ever have are like
clients wanting three times the amount
of work is what we formally agreed on
and signed
This is kind of crap, isn't it? And I
got to motivate myself to do this last
couple hours of stuff here.
One, two, three functions left, Okay.
engulf. We do actually have there's one
other um
uh there's one other finance client I
can think of that we still have active
that uh might be interested
if you emailed me some basics as well.
JS is at puffer
actually. Can you remind me, have you
contributed any ends with puffer? We do
um No, we do need people in that space
though. We're a little bit hesitant with
people who we've not directly like seen
code from.
This train is massive. We definitely
need to clean this.
We're at three 3420 lines, though.
That's really nice.
No. So, apocalyp that's not the so the
reason is that it's fast. It's really
simple.
Like it's simply much faster. So I don't
have to sit here for 15 minutes like
drooling while I wait for a simple
refactor.
I do actually I have the soul sub as
well and I've been using it less and
less. I've mostly just been using rock.
Like no it's not smart. It's very dumb.
But then again, like in my view, like
all the models are pretty dumb. I really
don't even notice that much when like
one model does something dumb versus
another cuz I've never I've never had a
model yet where I've been like, "Wow,
this is actually really capable and
smart."
Like they all write absolutely terrible
code, miss really obvious cleanups, add
lots of redundant crap, All right.
If you're a firm and two people can get
work done in time,
you should never have the throughput.
Um,
this is more so like I'm making all of
the key decisions here.
The models are nowhere near good enough
for a project like Puffer to do this
well. Like, yes, they can optimize
individual kernels. Sometimes they can
even jointly optimize things, right? Uh
they miss a lot of really important
research opportunities.
They write very bad code. Oh, I'm still
very much involved.
There we are.
It's fine.
This should be good, right?
No.
Not dealing with this stupid C++
warning. [ __ ] you, C++.
I did not get a proof of this, by the
way. So, this is whatever it is. Raw is
what it is.
Nice. See, we have a way simpler puff
penny gets
ulm fit type.
I've never heard of that.
This is a shitty Medium article. Where
is this?
This thing
Yeah, I don't I don't think that this is
this doesn't look remotely applicable.
We do have um we have a new RNN
architecture that it does work very
nicely for what we do.
Yeah, but language is kind of like one
big task where everything sort of
matches.
like RL looks very different as a
problem.
Like obviously, right? Why wouldn't it
come up with this? Cuz it's bad.
Okay, this is async. This is still in
development.
I've been improving it, Jess. It's still
a pain.
you improving the code at the very
least, right?
This is a mess.
A lot of this mess honestly is from
selfplay.
Piece of crap code. I swear
[sighs and gasps]
it's just hard to do this thing well.
Why never did it?
Let me just see if like what the hell
this is. This is just like
Okay, just legacy mess.
See, the funny thing is I haven't even
fully read this cuz how do you even
fully read this, right? I just look at a
block of code and I just go, that's too
much code for the thing that it's
implementing, right?
It's a very important thing to be able
to do. It's like,
no. It's like, well, no, it's clearly it
has to be super complicated cuz it's
hard. And I just look at it and go,
yeah, I don't buy that
Is that it?
Oh, I probably factored it out like a
dummy.
Let's say 30.
Okay.
No episode alignment.
Yeah, you can't have episode alignment
here, unfortunately,
unless it's a fixed timeout.
This, if anything, would be where you
would implement truncations. By the way,
This is down sample.
This is selfplay.
Okay, this is fun.
This is fun.
I think we could design this a little
bit better. I want to make a commit
though.
Oh, that's a very nice cut.
That's a very nice cut.
It ends up shorter.
Look at that.
Minus 20 lines.
It didn't find that either. By the way,
I just want to point out
soul like 5.6 x high Grock. They still
miss crap like this.
We can probably unify this more, but
this is already way better.
Yeah, this eval is different for now.
It's fine. What did the AI miss? It
missed that um it was like totally
duplicating a lot of the evaluation
logic between two functions. I pointed
out in its uh 20 line 20 line shaved
off, you know.
I mean it's just general code
restructuring Jess like bit by bit it's
like all right you know this thing is
obviously just bolted onto the existing
code like you don't just like it's not
add feature like thing exists then add
feature right it's like okay new feature
cool if the codebase is now going to
contain this like how should I design it
such that it contains both of these
things in the simplest way possible.
It was basically just like all the new
features being bolted on with absolutely
no consideration of how to redesign
accordingly.
And yeah, it's not easy. It takes time
to do it. That's why code bases get
bloated so easily, but you have to do
it.
Okay,
that's more reasonable. But
3384,
right?
stupid model
35 with lots of time learn this stuff
with sufficient time
it's Um
it's a combination of
uh systems programming,
machine learning fundamentals
and then uh a fair bit of like
reinforcement learning specific
knowledge. I will say that we do have
people that are contributing to Puffer
like we have a couple high schoolers
that occasionally submit reasonable
things uh quite a few undergrads. So
there's definitely some background
required and the high end of it like
there's a lot a lot to learn but I will
say it's at least 10 times easier to get
into than it was just a couple of years
ago. Oh,
any cool envy wish somebody worked on? I
mean, I think
research wise at the moment there are a
few complex ones. Um,
but for beginners, like we need more
self-play tasks.
Um, I'll give you an example of this. If
you go look up Robo Code, we already
have an end for this, but stuff like
that where that's like a 1v one tank
battle game. And it's nice because it's
pretty simple. It's not a huge amount of
code to implement. You can run it really
fast, but there are quite a good number
of different strategies. Uh there quite
a good number of different strategies
that emerge in it and there are a lot of
different scripted agents that you can
play against
makes it a very nice
task. [gasps]
Yeah, this is going to be much much much
deeper than um than HTML.
I mean it is the one nice thing I will
say is like there is stuff that people
can do with the first chunk of a basic
systems course already.
So I I generally think that
a lot of firstear undergrads who are
just taking their very first systems
programming course already can kind of
start doing stuff in this space and
understand you know a good amount of
what's going on. And um it's a pretty
smooth ramp from there.
So I'm not going to pretend it's trivial
cuz it's not trivial. But there is a
much smoother on ramp than there used to
be.
Like 3 years ago it was if you wanted to
do anything in this space like come back
when you have a PhD.
Now it's uh much much more reasonable I
would say.
Uh yeah, so Finn has been iterating on
Net Hack and Finn keeps shipping us
ridiculously good results all the time.
system stuff in high school.
Maybe some of them um unfortunat Well, I
don't know how they do it anymore to be
fair, but unfortunately when I was
taught I did start programming when I
was very young, but frankly the um
secondary education for programming is
awful. It's actually worse than not
teaching people programming in some
places. Like they teach you such an
awful way of programming that it it
literally takes you years to undo the
damage that they do. Um like how they
teach you to build things.
It's such a mess.
They very well could teach programming
this way in high school. It's not even
much more. It's like it's not even more
complicated
really.
But that's most it's mostly just an
education failure. There.
honestly, pen on p like pen and paper is
not the issue.
Like that's fine.
It's not ideal. Like
here it I do think that writing like
code with pen and p like that's a little
ridiculous but writing code in a text
editor
um with no lint or ability to run or
anything like that's fine.
So cuz just
I guess on like ruled paper maybe but
it's still just jank like because you
have indents and stuff. It's just weird.
So, I think it's like nonrunnable. Just
write the code fine, but pen and paper
is like eh. Also, you tend to have to
iterate on your code a lot more. So,
like just having the ability to edit the
stuff that you're writing it, you kind
of need that,
but very very close to pen and paper is
I'll say it's more close to fine than
it's to like ridiculous.
Um, you should not be getting rejected
by a state school for not having math
competitions.
Like, I'm an MIT PhD. I've never done a
math competition.
Language syntax rather than how comput
code work. Yeah. So that's why C is nice
because you can't learn C without
learning
like without learning what a computer
does.
Okay. Like the pen and paper thing is f
is fine if you just like if you write a
1 hour exam for 3 hours then sure.
But don't expect people to code on paper
fast.
Did you say let's see what did you what
age did you even say 35? Yeah,
35 is not old, dude.
And why is there no good research on
here? I swear.
Roger. I personally think that too many
people go to college in America.
Like a lot of the degrees are just
completely worthless. And then people
are just like profoundly unhappy trying
to find a very badly paying entrylevel
white collar job that has nothing to do
with what they studied when they'd be
way happier in a well-paying trade job.
There we go. Camera's way better with
that.
Where' the selfplay Evo go?
It's this thing.
If this doesn't work, I'm just going to
repeat the damn code
cuz this is ridiculous.
But you bring your own copy.
The heck.
What's the agenda? Hey Anesh,
I'm uh finishing cleaning up the puffer
file. Time is it? I probably got to head
out in like 15 20 minutes. I'd like to
finish this.
It's very annoying.
Yeah, Jess. I mean, it needs a lot of
testing still.
Runescape ends Valo is still working on
it. He keeps sending me updates. It's
almost ready for PR.
I actually messaged them PR soon. Also,
where's uh John Curtis? He was on here a
second ago. I want that fire uh that
fight cave NPR as well.
And I've just been I always get to doing
so much stuff. It's like
I'd like to not, but I don't really want
to special case it.
Dig Doug. [laughter] That's a fun one.
Yeah, that's chill.
That should be like a pretty short
little project. It's a fun one.
That was one of the few games I remember
from a long time ago. Oh, yeah. Yeah, I
had that, man.
Yeah. Yeah. This is exactly what I'm
thinking of.
You'll get like you'll get this thing
solved basically instantly.
I think the logic for this is pretty
simple, right?
look pretty and see.
Well, the graphics layer will be
separate, right?
Oh, there's John. They're working on it
last week. Open world RS
less encounter focused.
Yeah. So John, I think that the most
likely thing with RL in mind, right,
will be that um we can kind of drop
agents at individual challenges to begin
with. Then we can have the same policy
being dropped randomly at a bunch of
challenges to learn lots of things in
one policy and then we can try some more
openw worldy stuff.
Very excited. I just want to make sure
we at least get an initial PR so I can
help integrate stuff, you know.
cuz I definitely like I absolutely want
your M's, Volo M's, Craft Dax, Net Hack,
like that's five hard M's in Puffer 5.
Definitely want all that stuff
I think we can declare it like 90% done
and commit for now.
Also,
how fast is this thing
without a GPU?
1.8.
Good.
That's actually a negative. Um, that's
actually a net deletion, by the way. Uh,
we are not counting like stuff in the
crappy breakout code.
So, that's a net cut to the core.
10.5K.
Damn.
What even is this?
Okay, I There.
The reason again that I give it
something so broad is this protein code
is almost entirely AI gen or AI ported
from a contributor. So I have don't have
any attachment to it yet because like
basically nobody has bothered to go
through and look if it's any good. So
just like this starting point is as good
as a slightly different AI starting
point and uh we should have a very
strong bias to the file being shorter
papers use gym
planning research. If you want to be
able to do
like at home RL research,
Huffer Lib will be well over a thousand
times faster than anything based on gym.
So, as a matter of practicality, like
yeah, our stuff actually lets you run
experiments where otherwise you just
can't.
RL doesn't work when you run 10 million
time steps, man. It just doesn't.
what are your thoughts on neural nets?
Like
I don't know.
eight out of 10. They kind of model some
things, but I don't like how they remind
me of pomegranates and make me hungry.
want to start branching gamedev. Do you
prefer grock?
So, I don't really care very much about
the models because like for what I'm
doing, they're all sort of dumb. they
all make the same sort of dumb mistakes.
So, in my mind, I don't really care
whether I have one version behind like
because the labs kind of just leaprog
each other every other month. Anyways,
the reason I'm using Grock right now is
strictly because it's much faster and
that is important to me because I'm
basically making all of the technical
decisions here. Um, and I'm editing
stuff at the line by line level as well.
And waiting for an hour for the LM to
spin only to be wrong is completely
infuriating.
And yeah, that's about it.
So this here, like this is an example of
a much longer change where I could very
well have given this to Soul and just
have left for to go to dinner or
whatever. Um that and that would sort of
be fine, I guess. Um, but the only
reason that you see me doing a change
this big is because the file that I'm
changing, this was submitted by a
contributor. And this is a fully like
LLM port of our existing code. So, I'm
not remotely attached to the quality of
this thing at all. The quality is
already very low. And I want to refactor
it manually. and getting it as short as
possible while still being correct is
the best starting point for that which
is what this is doing now.
Trying to bring more selfplay Tron.
There actually was a guy that like did a
Tron like end and then just never
submitted it to us like the light bike
type game, right? Yeah, that would work.
That's that overlap with multi- aent
snake. Not really. It's like pretty
different to be fair. You're trying to
cover an area in that, aren't you? Or
are you just trying to um screw up your
opponent?
I guess you can play it either way,
right? It's like first to wipe out or
it's like largest area covered.
I think the territory control version is
interesting a lot more than the like
first to wipe version.
Uh, it would have to be strictly 1v one,
I think, because if you do more than one
v one, like elimination games are really
obnoxious when um
Yeah, elimination games are really
obnoxious,
Yeah, that'll be a fun little PR. Do the
uh you do the sign in red.
It fits Puffer very nicely.
It's a great way to get into Puffer as
well.
just like building a couple little ends.
High quality ones end up being pretty
widely used for research as well.
probably should go soon.
Yeah, it's 5:11.
Yeah, I think I should end stream
because I'm going to have to go to a
thing in a second. Um,
yeah, but this is uh this is pushed,
guys. So
10,544
lines, I think we'll get it to about
probably 10.3K after protein cleanup.
And then between the stupid puffer fish
loading and the CPU and like all the
other things, uh, they're going to very
easily be another 300 lines of cut. So
we will literally just be able to
release 10k line puffer five,
which will be a very nice
accomplishment.
For everybody who's new around here,
this is all open source.
Go ahead and start the repo on GitHub if
you haven't already. It actually really
does help me um surprising amount.
There's YouTube uh and Twitch,
obviously. You can follow me on X for
more RL content.
Uh and you can join the Discord if you
want to get involved with development.
That's where we coordinate everything
and there a bunch of helpful people in
there. I think I will probably be
streaming a little bit more refactoring
tomorrow as well as I owe uh Muffin, one
of the contributors, a environment code
review. I will probably do that
tomorrow. Thank you all. Have a nice
evening.